thank you
[Music]
did you guys know that Bitcoin is now
more stable than Amazon and metashares
amid this strange low volatility that's
going on in the market more stable so
it's not like volatile
like it was last year
well so it's annualized right so so like
yeah the the price volatility for
Bitcoin sits at an annualized rate of 32
percent which is a sharp reduction from
the all-time average of 71 so it's more
stable now you know some people assume
it's because more Bitcoin is distributed
now like almost I think 90 of Bitcoin
has been distributed 90 of the Bitcoin
that will ever be minted has been uh
distributed in our mind
um and so maybe that's why bitcoin's
prices settled out probably also it's
part of where Bitcoins are in the cycle
of like its own personal cycle that it
has doesn't it does that mean that like
it won't you won't see those crazy gains
like before if it's more stable there's
a there's a lot of thinking behind it
that that is possible Right like maybe
the Market's so realized with Bitcoin uh
I don't personally think so but that's
my own personal belief but here's
Bitcoin right now like being more stable
than a lot of these other stocks like
like Amazon meta wow right probably the
banking crisis stuff probably helped out
a lot too to make it more definitely and
this might be a safer bet than leaving
my money in the bank right now and that
narrative really played hard actually
like all these Banks were following
guess what was going up right crypto
yeah so um people believe that that's
probably why but you know whenever you I
really like this story because whenever
you hear the name Bitcoin or crypto
people always just hear like they hear
crash rise I wish I got some crap scam
right it's not real yeah right all that
but this is kind of like one of those
things where you can see an example of
here it is it's actually less volatile
than a lot of these stocks up there what
are your thoughts on this
like well I believe in it so I think I
think it's um
you believe in it so it's like a
religion whoa that makes me more money
than yeah it helps you out yeah right
yeah how do you look at it versus like
traditional stocks or tradfly
um
like you look at traditional stocks it's
I think I think all of it's similar just
depends on where the market's at what's
is the crisis happening in the world or
something happening you know things move
around and it's just seeing Bitcoin over
the years and watching at your light
table it's it's not going anywhere and
those bank I think this banking thing
and and during the pandemic also
reassured me a little more that I'm like
okay I'm gonna stick with this do you
have uh stocks too I do and both yeah do
you like have a certain way like I like
this percentage in like stocks this
percentage and crypto so I think I'm
still trying to learn it because I'm
still a lot I think I've only had a few
years in it in it so I'm just still like
testing the market
um playing my percentage is how much I
put into each one just paying it depends
on what Market State we're in What's
Done better for you personally
um take us inside crypto's definitely
taking me making made me a good amount
of money yeah oh yeah wish I could say
the same I don't know well we made a lot
but that's in the past tense yeah yeah
it's a different time now a little bit
what's your take on the current market
um
we'll see I guess I'm I'm just holding
steady right now I'm just painting is
watching daily and see what happens
there's like everyone's doing that are
you a hodler yeah are you a daily cost
average man DCA that's what that's
I just I'm just trying I'm just trying
to be smarter watching the last few
years happen not trying to chase but
everyone's chasing it when everything
goes up like goes crazy and just keep
dumping like you know the younger kids
which Dogecoin you got
too much you dump it you went all in
Pepe because I did not go Pepe at all
but did you see a lot of my friends the
younger kids were going in on it did you
see that class action that's going
against Elon right now for the Doge yep
you said that you would buy during dips
like how much do you buy when like a dip
happens
I just
I guess just depends on my comfort level
how much it dipped and where you know I
think when I dropped down to
13 15 grand I think I bought it I bought
a pretty good I bought a pretty good
amount at 13 Grand yeah so you already
took us from there from just that jumped
on this way right now it's like what's a
pretty good amount yeah a give or take
yeah
within a couple cents yeah just say with
this face too
and throw it away
six figure numbers
great amount so anywhere from 100K to
900k yeah somewhere in there that's not
a lot at all
that's a small amount yeah that's
probably the smallest amount I've ever
tax that's pre-taxed yeah yeah he's
getting [__] railed in the end yeah
you're getting so when you say you buy
like a large amount what would you say
like the large amount yeah
probably like nine things let's say you
put your product key like just on yeah
what's your secret key
and why when you first got into uh like
Bitcoin and ethereum like what was the
price at and where did you first oh I
didn't even buy until I didn't buy until
late I didn't buy until
[Music]
oh that's Noob [__] yeah that was like
one I bought it that's it
maybe I'll find a little bit I'll find
like tiny bits in like 2020 but 2021
that's when I started you know yeah
because I was trying to buy them you
signed up to go 70 and then you start to
come all the way down coming down oh I
should buy at 15. well that's because I
was like now I'm gonna go into this nft
thing I need to buy a lot more
Gary's wish to God you were part of me
and Joe's program money Masters we would
have taught you a lot where we told
people that you know ethereum's cool at
80 bucks and then but everyone was
calling us and saying what a bunch of
jokers we taught them in 2020.
but they were saying they were just wish
to Absolute Jesus
if you were a part of our money Masters
course
we would have got you in Pretty Sweet
yeah do you ever like like lay down you
ever like pray like go like this that
you were at my wedding in 2017 when I
was helping people set up ethereum walks
100 bucks
yes absolutely yeah it is driving home
and be like [__] I should have went to
his wedding
I know people who are millionaires
because they went to my wedding how
crazy is that wow that's pretty [__]
crazy it's pretty powerful stuff that's
pretty
I never went back once I got obsessed
like that's how I am of an obsessive
personality if I really am passionate
but yeah I [__] like ham on crypto
for sure look at my life look at me
every Tuesday night I do a show about
crypto [__] two hours
I do it every I've never been more
consistent with anything in my life
that's pretty tight yeah like I've been
uploading to my Stephen Comedy Channel
like the privately to my patreon group
for [__] two years plus every week
how many members do you have in it
I'm part of it but do you ever do you
ever like look at crypto as do you see
it just as a business thing or do you
see it as just a way to make more money
or I see as a business I think I think
the tech side of it in the future this
whole web 3 thing is
it's going to change it's going to
change a lot of things going forward I
think I think as as people start
adopting it more and people understand
the real use of it what's the sexiest
application of web3 that you can
describe to people
sexiest I don't know about sexy is I
just I just like the technology of
things being on the blockchain and you
know verifying and it being a better
type of loyalty program and providing
different types of value of being a part
of that loyalty program I guess yeah it
makes sense yeah
there's a lot of utility that is going
to happen through it yeah just people
are figuring it out right now as more
people adopt it and see that hey this
it's actually legit and you know
everyone else is going to hop on I mean
you're figuring it out right now
yeah you did a lot for it do you think
there's gonna be anything that's gonna
change with the implementation of like
more AI stuff or do you think it's going
to be kind of like
do you think it's gonna affect it at all
AI is affecting everything yeah yeah but
right now what can it do really I mean
it's it's sort of like um
a q a stuff you know what do you think
about it it's like
it's gonna it's gonna read into Data a
lot better like things that a normal
person can't do like you can't you know
go through access all this data and
figure things out this fast but I think
yeah I'll help I'll speed that process
up
it can help you read a white paper if
you're into crypto like it can help you
like like it could spit out like a
better summary than like you could do
probably like taking an hour for
yourself to do it what's the white paper
well it's like a crypto's use case like
what they're trying to do and their
tokenomics what they're what they're
what they're why okay please don't talk
down to me imagine like um it's almost
like um yeah
you know what's funny about attention
spans in the world though so that white
papers used to be like the common common
thing and now they have a thing called
light papers because they try to do a
summary of this yeah so it's you know
they're like here you go for like those
of you who aren't going to read for too
long come by at the old paper but if
you're gonna spend thousands of dollars
on something don't you kind of want to
read it you would think but things look
at [__] like Pepe yeah yeah people just
buying it and there's nothing behind it
that's just like yeah I believe I think
it's just fun huh if everyone's doing it
I think people just a lot of people in
general from stocks of crypto so I
really just want a like a a version of
gambling that doesn't seem like gambling
but they they're actually guilty as
charge hey everything's a [__]
gamble dude buying a house is a gamble
yeah that's true look at interest rates
yeah but it's just less of a risk and if
you do your research is less of a gamble
yeah yeah in anything and anything you
do it's more of a calculated estimate at
that point if you did your due diligence
correctly
but in my case you're my due diligence
and I did it correctly because you're my
light paper
hey not bad to be up uh 80 in six months
not the cardano guys I'll tell you that
those guys are dead in the water I just
like to pour more dirt on them more and
more Durham we need to do a whole woo
compilation in the future when we win
and then like compared to the Cardinal
pushers of 2020 2021 2020 and how much
they chain bro bro there's so much going
on under the hood of crypto right now
like like my baby my other baby kujira
like the way that it's catching up to
this major project that still people
don't know about called injective is
sexy and it is just like
you know we're just gonna win we're
gonna do it again what we do we do it
every [__] time I bring out the woo
girls
white girls would just say woo yeah
[Laughter]
thank you